re
突然ですが
私は
トイレが大好きです
小学校2年生の時に品ようになってから
トイレを探す毎日が続き
トイレを探すことが癖になりそれが
きっかけで私はトイレを愛して病まなく
なりました
悩んだり怒ったり泣きたくなったり
そうしてそこそんな時に行くのがトイレ
です
トイレがないってなっただけで私はもう
不安でいっぱいになります
徹のことばっかり毎日考えているので夢の
中にはトイレがしょっちゅう出てきます
そこで私は何とかそこあーおしっこがした
いって思って
と会に行くんですけどスッキリしなくて
いつも悔しい思いをします
でただ起きた時に漏らしてなくて良かっ
たって思うことがしょっちゅうです
皆さんにも今日は私がどれだけトイレを
愛しているかその愛が少しでも伝わって
少しでも皆さんにトイレを id を持っ
てもらうためにお話したいと思います
さて皆さん
刀流について皆さんはどのようにお考え
ですか
当たり前にある
普段の日常生活でとても当たり前にあって
意識することもなく使っているし感謝する
こともなく使っていると思いますもし感謝
するとすればお腹が痛くなって頭家に
駆け込んだときにあぁここにトイレがあっ
て本当に良かったって思う時ぐらいだと
思います
ただ
人が生まれて一つの場所に住み始めて定住
が始まってから実はトイレの闘いという
ものがありました
そしてトイレの戦いというのは今でも実は
連綿と続いているんです
皆さん
水洗トイレがいつ生まれたかご存知ですか
実は今から4000年前
メソポタミア文明の遺跡からトイレが
見つかっています
そこで使われている推薦東映っていうのは
今の推薦通りはちょっと違って川の水を町
に引き込んでそこに雲長おしっこを
落とし込んでそれを釜に押し戻すという
仕組みです
ローマ帝国の時にはこのトイレというもの
が全盛期を迎えます待ち中に公衆トイレが
設置されます
しかしながらキリスト教農政で投影という
ものは浮上であるというところから講習の
場から姿を消してしまいます
飲んで講習のものだったトイレが個人の
もとのもののトイレとなりそこで出てきた
のがを丸です
家の中でおまるに雲長執行用を足すわけ
ですがその中身をその当時の人たちはどの
ように処理していたでしょうか
階段を降りるのが面倒くさいなと感じ始め
た人たちは
窓この外に投げ捨てるんです
道路はうんちおしっこでめちゃめちゃです
し
街を歩いていると上から文鳥思考が降って
くるわけです
最悪です
それを避けるために生まれたものが今や
オシャレアイテムとしてなっているハイ
ヒール
もしくはつばの広い帽子だったりマントと
言われています
必要は発明の母なんですね
でっ
うんちやおしっこが街にあふれていてま
汚い臭いだけで済めばいいんですけども
それだけじゃ全然進まないんです
それが原因でチフスやペストなど伝染病が
流行ります大流行します
14世紀中頃には
世界人口の3分の1がそれで命を落とした
と言われています
どうにかせな快感ってことで16世紀頃に
なって初めて現代型の水洗トイレという
ものが発明されました
これによって建物に溜まってた雲長しっこ
が川や海などに運ぶことに成功ができた
わけですただこれでは館完璧じゃなくて
20世紀なて下水処理施設
この下水処理技術が発明されて安全で衛生
的なトイレというのが完結することができ
ました
じゃあその時に本店どうだったんでしょう
か
日本では鎌倉時代ぐらいからお寺にトイレ
というものがどんどん設置されて一般化し
ていきます
その当時の日本ではご飯を食べてそのあと
うんちおしっこを出して出てきたものを
集めてで疲労にするために寝かしてそして
作られた放るんをはだけ野菜を育てるため
に使ってその育った野菜をまだ食べると
いうような循環型のクラシーというものが
そこにありました
江戸の町では
費用家と呼ばれるういちおしっこ貯める
ためのお気を持った人たちが長屋の主を
訪れてそのうんちいくらで売ってくれって
いうような状態ですこの当時雰囲気は
おしっこは価値あるものだったのできんぴ
と呼ばれてました
当時の日本は鎖国をしていたので輸出入に
制限があります
なのでその時の日本はほぼ完全な循環型の
暮らしというのがされていました
ただ
開国されますとその循環型のサイクルって
いうのは少しずつ崩れていきます
人は仕事を求めて都市にどんどん集まって
きます
人が集まるとそこで生み出されるのは運賃
おしっこです
必要量以上年イチョウ執行が集まると活用
はどんどん下落します
今までお金で売れていたうんちやおしっこ
というものがそれからはお金を払って雲長
執行を運んでもらう
そういうものになりました
サラミ
ボットン便所に溜まった41おしっこは
バキュームカーを使って農村部に運ばれて
いきます
その肥料を作るのにもだんだんお金が
かかってきますそして海外からは安い化学
肥料が輸入されてきます
文鳥執行肥料化するコストがかかるに比べ
て海に捨てた方が早いし安いということで
出てきたうん銚子港海に捨てるということ
が始まります
そしてその海に捨てることが環境に問題
まあ環境破壊につながるということで禁止
されてからは下水処理技術が日本にも導入
されて今のような形で安全で快適に不自由
なく遠いが使えるように日本もなったわけ
です
じゃあ
考えてみてください
今私たちが使っている通りですが世界に目
を向けると
果たしてどうなんでしょうか
国連によると
25億人の者たちが定期的に東映に
アクセスできない状況が今でも続いてい
ます
そして10億人の人たちは
屋外で排泄することを余儀なくされてい
ます
その人たちがほとんど住んでいるのは新興
国です
新興国は今人口が爆発的に増えてます
人々は仕事を求めて都市に集まります
ただお金がないので住む場所は上水道や
下水道インフラの整っていないスラム地区
です
この写真は私が今働いているケニアの最大
のスラム木べらになりますここには
もちろん上下水道インフラはありません
ただ公衆トイレは数少ないですが存在し
ます
ただこの通りでを使うのには10円や5円
お金がかかります
そして夜このトイレに行くことは大変危険
です
子どもたちや女性がそこの投影に行く
なんてことはもってのほかです
お金がない人そして
夜トイレに行きたくなった人どうやって用
を足すんでしょうか
その一つの方法がコレです
フライングトイレです
名前の通り空を飛ぶトイレです
これは
どうしても取れ行きたくなったでも通れ
ないどうしようってなったらとりあえず
そこにあるビニール袋にアンチっていう
感じです
ただ家に置いておくとすごく臭うのでこの
トイレを外に向かって放り投げるんです
だからフライングトイレなんです
じゃ投げた先どうなっちゃう
これはその木べらの一角です
砥山のようにビニール袋に入ったゴミが
積み重なってますしこの中の半分ぐらいは
そのフライング通れるに超指向が入った
ものです
ビニール袋を破れて簡単に外にこぼれがし
ます
そしてその側ではこの写真にも写っている
ように子供たちは楽しそうに泥で遊ぶん
です
この道路雲長執行が入っている可能性
すごい高いです
その手のまま彼女たち彼らはこのご飯を
食べますだからゲリンのある子がすごく
多いんです
ユニセフだと1日2400人の子どもたち
がこれで命をそして落としています
なんとかしなきゃいけないです
じゃあ先進国がとった方法を取ることが
一番いいかもしれないだけどもそれができ
ないんです
水がないんです
8億人の人たちは
未だに飲む水を手に入れるのに苦労して
ます
先ほどのスラムでも上水道が無いのないの
で生きるための水を手に入れるのが精一杯
です
そんな水をうんちおしっこを流すため
なんか使うことはできません
そうだから私は今ケニアでこの問題を解決
するために働いています
私が今作っているのは循環型の水筒入れ
システムという新しいトイレです
名前の通り水を使いません
そしてで行ってきた雲長執行を肥料にして
土に戻す循環型の仕組みを目指しています
ここで目指してる私たち私のありたい社会
の姿っていうのは食べてだして集めてまた
肥料にするために寝かして野菜を育てて
その野菜をまた食べるって言う循環型の
暮らしです皆さん見覚えありますよね
そうです私たちが日本でやってたその
暮らしです
またその私はその暮らしをケニアで実現し
たいと思っています
なぜ私が循環型にこだわっているかと言う
と人口が増えると水の問題と合わせて食料
の問題が出てくるんです
私たちの運賃おしっこにはまだまだ使える
栄養素が残ってるんだからその資源を賢く
回収してまたそれを位置に戻すことで環境
に優しい社会というのが持続できます
このコンセプトは十分わかっていただける
ケニアの人たちもわかるかもしれないけど
も昔のようなボットン便所だったらこんな
の使いたくないってなかなか受けてもらえ
ませんだから私たちは快適性にもこだわっ
てます
私が作っている循環型も水稲会では雲長
執行分けて回収することができます
これによって臭いの元であるアンモニアの
発生を抑えることができます
この循環型の暮らしということそして快適
なトイレということをこの愛でをケニアの
人たちに伝えて理解して共感を得て
それをでケニアにこれを普及させていき
たい
それが私の毎日の活動です
イギリスで500年前に現代型の推薦答礼
が開発されてから今私は次の世代に
つながるトイレというものを開発している
そんな意気込みで前にシュンとしています
私はこのトイレをケニアで成功させた後
やりたいことがあります
それはこのトイレを日本に持って帰りたい
ことです
なんででしょうか
それは日本が地震大国だからです
一度大きな地震が起きると高い確率で断水
が起きます
断水が起きると今ある水洗トイレは使い物
になりません
たとえ水道が治ったとしても
下水道管や下水処理場が壊れたままだと
トイレも使えないんです
仮設トイレはもちろんきますが回収する
ための二トラックが来なかったら使い物に
なりません
私たちに残されているトイレの方法は
ビニール袋にウンチオシッコをしてそれを
回収常に持っていくまさに私がスラムで見
ている生活をしなければなりません
次に起きるかもしれない
災害にも立ち向かうためにも
上下水道インフラに依存しないトイレの
開発が今から必要だと思っています
そして水を使うことも日本ではもったい
ないと思っています
日本は水が豊かな国と皆さん持っているか
もしれませんが決して豊かではないんです
雨は多く降るんですけどもためることが
できません
すぐに海に流れ出してしまいます
そして水日本は水を輸入する最大の輸入国
としても知られています
食べ物をたくさん輸入してますがその
食べ物を作るために海外で多くの水を使っ
ています日本でそれだけの食べ物を作ろう
としても水がなくてまかなうことができ
ないんです
水を作るために私たちはたくさんの
エネルギーを使ってます
川上から川下まで
浄水処理下水処理これを繰り返して再利用
してなんとか使ってます分かりにくいかも
しれませんが日本でも今水面下では東レと
の戦いは続いていますし災害がひとたび
起きるとこの闘いに私たちを直面する可能
性があります
だから私からこの闘いに迎えた準備として
提案があります
皆さん
トレに
愛を向けてみませんか
今まで意識にしなかった投影に意識を向け
て考えてみませんか
遠い例を考えることそれは今の私たちの
環境そして私たちの未来の環境を考える
ことにもつながります
恥ずかしがらずに皆さんと色を愛してみ
ましょう
すごく簡単なことかもしれませんが例えば
皆さんトイレに大小洗浄機能がついている
のご存知ですか
ちゃんと使い分けてみますか
あの機能は日本で生まれたもので海外では
とても絶賛されています
正しく使い分ければ家族4人の場合年間
2,000リットルの水を節約できます
あと
トイレをするのにまぁ必ず必要な
トイレットペーパーを使いすぎてませんか
ねぇ
と言うとペーパーて実は分値に比べて流す
ために使う水とか処理に使うエネルギー
多いんです
なのでこれをちょっとでも減らすことって
いうのが環境の為にもエネルギーを削減
するためにもすごく役に立つんです
トイレっていうのはそこが決して出口じゃ
なくて実は入口なんです
うんちの食べてそこから始まるんです
その度に少し高思いを馳せて考えてみる
ことそれが実は環境にを考えることに
つながっていきます
皆さんが少しでも投影に感心を持って
ちょっとずつの愛を注ぎ込んでもらうこと
それがこの後の将来的な環境にもつながっ
ていきます
今入った少しの改善活動行動は今の環境を
変えるのでも役に立ちますし将来的に循環
型結びトイレが日本に入ってきた時の準備
にもつながっていきます
皆さんといや2杯を向けてみましょう
改めて最後に
トイレに愛を
ありがとうございましたん